and he was always opposing very much to
the equations and the comparisons and
the comparisons indeed I do want to have
another just inside before that the
comparisons are so annoying and this is
another cause for fatigue Sabah Mago
entered the remodeling 2002 and he was
five hours in Ramallah and then he said
this is outfits and it was a very
unfortunate unfortunate incident because
he came with a delegation of writers and
we hoped very much that they would be
able to give to talk sense to some
Israelis at that time who refused to see
what was happening and when he said this
is Auschwitz he just blew it all then I
wrote a sentence for when I did when I
reported about it when I wrote I wrote a
sentence that my editors didn't he
raised I said well this is when he it is
out of it when he enters Ramallah what
comparison will he have left will be
left for him when he goes tomorrow to
Gaza so this is something about
comparisons but going back and ending
with what my father said he said okay
with us and we know it was extermination
it was five years six years but we knew
it ended it came to an end but with the
Palestinians it is not ending it is
going on it is 48 and it is beyond that
is more and more so Who am I not to
compare thank
okay um that was very that was very
profound I think both presentations um
I'm going to ask the questioners to ask
a question one question please and
please do make them questions um so
please go ahead and I will
yeah I was just wondering super said
that Israeli on George Washington
exterminate do you think Israel is not
committing genocide if it's a held back
by other forces in the world or you know
because they're not that bad and they're
not that bad yet but will they possibly
become
why don't we take that's incorrect okay
thank you um professor asked are you
mentioned the pump the idea of context
that we have to see things in context no
one here is mentioned and by the way i
do deplore murder wherever it happens
but what about the context that israelis
feel with possibly good cause that the
Arab world or factions of the Arab world
would like to push them into the sea
that's another context that happen to
mention this is a question to Professor
a scar on a scroll of the Second World
War and one of the troubling aspects of
what happened during the war when you
read the post narrative arguments or
discussed here is the fact that two
waffen-ss addition the 13th 21st
waffen-ss addition former Yugoslavia
predominately of Muslims were mentored
at clients by the ground hopefully next
time and I wonder how you sort of
understand or contextualize this in a
book
any one more question by questioning the
net award merits there is mostly seems
to be about an Ashkenazi the European
Jewish experience in the Arabic script
but of course is also the experience of
Jews in the Middle East and giving of
them is rocking and the symphony of war
of narratives of three multiple
narratives on the one hand you have a
narrative from an Arab side the
beautiful people who are dupes of the
Zionist name and pawns in the other hand
of the Zionists and their victims of
anti-semitism the persecution and among
the ruffian themselves many often
conflicting narratives no wonder how the
narrative of the Holocaust per capita
European Jews that fits into a large
portion of the Israeli population that
has admit Middle East and Jewish origin
stop there
when the light post yes
I react to the questions destiny the
context issue it's really side facing
facing us want to throw them see when I
mean indeed I mean director think that
very much in the consideration the fact
that this has been implicated in these
waves that they are facing not only
people told them to see people want to
commit genocide but what is the actual
basis I mean this is just mythical
because even any I mean of course had
this attitude his position was that old
Jewish device after night incident the
end of this after the beginning of
British combination of palestine should
should go back to wherever they came
from and when they came back to her
about the Second World War this is the
line that he wanted the Arab states
forward and he was not even out of state
and our state in 46 47 Berlin Ohio
State's which conducted the negotiations
with the international permissions about
Palestine put forward a blueprint for a
bi-national state was a proportional
presentation of all those Jews in
Palestine at that time Destery and
that's the real program that they were
faced facing and and if the rest is is
of course I can find people with the
extremist news all the time but the fact
is that this depiction of the enemy is
represented like the notification that I
mentioned as an argument to justify the
unjustifiable and argument to justify
ethnic things and we see it at its
crudest in Benny Morris ready historian
famous scandalous 2004 interview Red's
where he he said and you know anymore is
probably also if you know but has been
played a decisive role in establishing
on his right beside the the fact of the
sponsorship in 1948 and knowledge great
explosion with some limitations that
people and so in that interview he was
openly the term ethnic cleansing to
describe what happen until okay but then
he justified this epicness because he
says when the Eternity was generous to
this either we committed this ethnic
cleansing or we would have been victims
of genocide problem from Paris why so
because our Muslim are barbarians their
religion is Jenna cyber they should be
put in cages and dressing that that was
really scary but basically this argument
is there this is a justification
specification of the conflict is used
education as a pretext to justify this
continuous history of actual not
negative oppression uprooting ethnic
cleansing and war crimes crimes against
humanity and we can't be less critical
than that devout Jew enzyme is the judge
costume in his report about Gaza so this
is this is the the SS units in Bosnia
that would be contributing up I did with
that in the book itself I mean anyway
anyhow any form of collaborations
Masterson is entrancing but in this case
they were not at all instrumental in the
gym they did not accept very much and
commit any Jewish exceptions and
actually those who join these units did
it they were seeking and that's what the
most conservatives as an explanation for
his role in establishing a student's not
as something our units dedicated 20
Jewish causes but as a shield or a way
of shielding different self defending
the force and Muslims from
its actions by Serbian fascist forces
and that that's what he what he strains
although in his memoirs and know that he
certainly does not pretend to be a few
semi his anti-semitic this course is
quite open but so and he doesn't even
pretend to do that he wasn't aware of
genocide and all that but yet here in
this concrete case that that was what
happened actually one of the those
students is the only unity services
which went into a mutiny when they were
sent out of area of their area of the
Vulcans into France and that they might
communion many of them joined the
partisan groups in the fight against
that's so we have to hear again to check
a real historical record and also not
forget that the only country in group
where there were no Jules after growth
and the photo is the only Muslim
continue
the question why Israel does not commit
genocide I find it a very difficult
almost obscene question to invite you I
don't think the big such questions
should be asked for the same East we
asked about certain date with something
happen
you know we're responding it's like
collaborating with obscenities maybe
yes was constantly back and was it
outside
for me I'm sorry
okay I'm sorry but look the fact is
let's let see the facts the facts that
you have the Palestinian population
grows inside inside Israel inside the
Palestinians often i tell police that
this is one of the things that I've
learned when I was in Gaza and because I
know Gaza the problem of the blockade of
Gaza is not about food it's not about
starvation people are not being starved
to death the essence of Israeli policies
today is active oil I believe to foil
any possible solution fair solution so
that they could continue to keep Jewish
to germany in the region to prevent
Palestinians from exercising either in a
fair way they are right they arise as a
people with self-determination and in
according to the International and
orbital internet
resolutions and understanding to prolong
this as much as possible from 48 to keep
this as as long as possible away from 48
with the memory face so they think in
profit from the occupation they profit
from being there but of course there is
i would say other things are more other
what other terrible things are possible
like mess expansions a continuation or
what many more is making wishes to pc
transfer to jordan you hear you here
Israeli leaders speaking now openly
about this option of Jordan as the other
part is the SD Palestinian state the
endless two-state solution is Israel and
n jordan this little troop is ready a
two-state solution a few months a few
weeks ago there was a pilot exercise in
the simulation done by Israeli we need
to
in container coordination the military
prison authorities the police and the
Shabak simulating the situation what
they will have to have mass arrests of
Palestinians when in case there is a
agreement implemented by the Israelis
and the Palestinians which involves the
transfer of population so in that case
so of course they are they are scenarios
that maybe 20 years ago in fact 10 years
ago most Israelis who would feel
embarrassed or ashamed to raise but i
feel that will be raising a possibility
we make it a possibility so that's why i
say no we have to see what is what is in
reality today the reality the urgency
today is indeed to raise a voice the
urgency today is of expulsion in israel
actually exercises many expansions on a
smaller scale where I see that the need
the dead man to start the reality of
understands it has been created over the
past 20 years is actually a compromise
is a compromise between the general we
know
to transfer Palestinians from the
country and an acknowledgement of the
political reality does not allow for
such now for such mass expulsion and
this is why the dissolution the
individuals is to condense the
Palestinian about customs Gaza is one
understand and then you have in the West
Bank the a and B and place that were
created by Oslo and twisty understanding
of the party city this is all only
temporary and today they are totally
helpless to fight against it so this I'm
sorry that I said but I but yeah I have
now I have now to admit the transfer as
a possibility ms France there is more is
more stable into a girl when you take it
very forces that it was 20 years ago now
as for the narrative the Holocaust
clarity in Israel when how it applies to
with rocky juice or knowledge callosity
first it was a big segment of Sarathi
truth my mother among them in Europe but
also in oven
northern Africa who were also victims
and potential victims of of the Nazis so
this is something we should remember but
it's drawn it in Israel for many years
the I could personally I could detect
among non Ashkenazi Jews or jews from
arab countries in Muslim countries also
a thought is a very similar Holocaust
went in with you you fight among
Palestinians because it was not used and
taken is there as one of the assets to
pay per Ashkenazi Jews with their
privileges in comparison to the
knowledge kannada news that there were
similar reactions of other mining gold
or or the new team will affect
trivializing trivializing the the
experience of the Holocaust I I remember
there was a demonstration
also my father is a hero to the AC and
here but also demonstration in is the
presenters killing the palestinian girl
in gaza then it was it happened once and
then we thought this it was the worst
thing that could have could happen and
one guy I remember it very clearly
shouted my father go back to Auschwitz
and he was clearly and knowledge canale
jus okay this was also but now the
propaganda is so that don't nobody would
dare to say now it is it has become a
state religion of the book so everybody
is abiding by the state religion I want
you say what about the movie tomorrow
and just read a car it's a few months
ago that there was a few dozens of
Israel of a Jewish Jews in Finland who
fought with the not a with a finnish
army with the Germans against the Soviet
Army finished juice yes and they won't
because the fields were at war and
independence war against against the
against the Soviets and the Allies were
Germans and they join them Paris more
questions the question do on the sauce
first thank you so much for all through
this work that you know sadness from
concerning the question is a few a few
years ago professor alarm papi who wrote
the ethnic cleansing of palestine seems
that he was the rest who was not fired
but he was the last and not threatened
enough and he had to leave israel and
find work in England now it sounds also
like there's an increase in a lot of
racism Israel against Palestinians in
the last few years probably
unprecedented how do writers like you
will progressive people who say that
principle where I all this work and who
I should collaborate sometime with the
Palestinians will do some solidarity
work of the company how do you survive
in this atmosphere do you get harassed
just like Professor is unpopular
officially or unofficially and what do
you do personally like psychologically
live in its atmosphere i also have a few
friends who are on the left in Israel
for the very first time say it's so
poisonous we've lost so many friends and
family that we never believe you know
they were liberal and little party
supporters and they're thinking about
leaving this
the very first time if you can see
people I appreciated your talks and I
think we've heard a lot of sort of
comparing which kind of racism is worse
and murderer versus colonialism and
stuff but is it may be more important to
make a comparison and think about racism
and maybe nationalism limits on the part
of the weaker or more press party as
being harmful to any of those ordinary
people who are living in either
situation because it seems to me what
this racism where nationalism does is
destroy people's ability to correctly
analyze and fight back about their
situation I mean in Israel we have a
country that's really the pawn of
america and the imperialists who could
even profit at some point in his real
has created itself a situation of hatred
which gives it a great risk of the whole
country being destroyed and you also
have a country with tremendous
differences of wealth and power where
the most Israelis that are doing very
badly economically at this point art or
not looking at their society but our or
one over to this idea of blaming and
Haiti Palestinians and even within
you have no okay you have great
differentiations in wealth and power and
you have the same problem or for
Palestinians he won more to nationalism
than to thinking about what kind of
society they need for themselves and
even integrating themselves together
were Israelis and Palestinians like the
question dude professor operation
microphone right I'm just wondering a
tarag Ramadan he came earlier in the
year to New York and he meet for the
first time he was alive back in the
country and use us is being followed by
a by a journalist from the New York 19 /
Tucker and he was asked specifically
about a show for hasn't abandoned and
his relations with Amina saini and I'm
how he how arrogant and felt about that
diagram of an answer in terms of mean
that he had the beat that hasn't run out
and I've seen in terms of past I was
your friend of your any enemy of your
mind is this my name is my name yeah he
said that and that was not satisfactory
for him a four-foot George Packer
relation to answering that issue he felt
that Tiger island wasn't ready to
distance himself enough from heaven bana
and from 13 and to Tamara I remember
very clearly the issue with saramago
that you mentioned the earlier and I
remember your reaction to that but I was
wondering how you thought about you know
the fact that right I you know I wonder
how far the fact that you know in a way
when that happened I felt that we have
so grown up with education about the
Holocaust and if you got such a I think
something that Professor rashguards
mention it becomes such a meter of evil
and violence to to all of us Jews and
non-jews there's just those of
combatants are inevitable i was thinking
of natural science play earlier this
year that thought about it say who
mentions in her father in his dying days
when he was delirious saying that he
only started packing any tags and his
wife come out to him and said what are
you doing and he said some IV my bad
because the Nazis are coming so it was
so much in his subconscious as a lot of
that sense of persecution and such a
natural reaction and I wonder what you
you would be good one more one work done
there's a lady will you talk to Michael
yes they are going to make remarks I'll
say hello and for for being here my
question is more actually a reaction to
this house said about the sanity of the
comparison that were made after session
you will be questioned about genocide
versus transfer various there's a kind
of thin lining but that separates
between the develop it excessively of
this year ago people to stay ahead with
sabra and shatila word passively
genocide you know with Israeli
protection but you see something about
this about how does this sit in the
sleep picture because you transfer other
singers out if you want lowball but
there's a problem how is that different
from killing them
yes well I don't do this the interview
that was sort of Ramadan but hasn't
Magna is one thing I mean is considered
a very high consideration or same
bread but they did not collaborate the
George most intuitive sense of the term
with Madison insanely did it has a
magnetism contradictory statements he
made by these points but basically they
deserve it support for Fordham of tea
one hand as someone sharing with them
some central crucial element ideology
and also I should say because it goes
beyond innermost another scene
population I don't mind the book that
after 45 up to 48
the city still enjoyed more popularity
than an opinion leader among the
Palestinians but that's awesome and
because of in something that we're in
the record seen in a recurrent way the
demonisation by those who oppress you
the demonization of somebody makes the
somebody makes you that shows anymore
that's not seem less regularly you can
even see how for instance the having a
huge difference between yessir are five
percent but I'm just kidding explaining
how the demonization of Yasser Arafat
word sensor that was I mean crucial
factor in his popularity and how when
his popularity went down no way Janine
and then up again when he was put under
kind of house arrest by sheldon de papa
so I mean this is a sailor other
so I mean whatever was said about has
Amanda to speak here of the enemy of you
Sarah me as the nation forwards attitude
might be accepted for a Savannah it
certainly is not acceptable for I mean
same it was the crucial difference as I
said is that he knew one about genocide
and secondly this not prevent him from
making speeches full Nancy like
anti-semitism a discussion of the Jews
of the worst episode as somatic from
Nazi propaganda well the king of Macedon
it has hardly mentioned i want to just
comment on that this issue of the
comparison was dancing in a sense i
quote like embarrassed one of the most
famous historian in our studies who say
something very sensible if people resort
so much comparison was legitimate and as
you know it stopped the preserve the
middle east
find them you have found them so many
times over the case of a civil war but
that's because Manson has become at each
standard of evil and in a sense this is
actually of course healthier than the
same as it was nice or or or whatever I
mean even better do is you cannot be
suspected of any proper skinny
sympathies but said it's it's better
that they use that to them as an insight
then they say when the weather don't
finish the job or something like that so
we have also taken into consideration
and finally this issue of thin line
between genocide and transfer what is
the purpose of saying that is a thin
line for you to be expect from your
house or being killed I mean it exists
between the do you see are a thin line I
mean this is awesome unacceptable that
to say that it's a thin line stand no it
does have a deep qualitative difference
between a genocide and a mass expulsion
both are crammed into many people all
the stuff you f convinces a crime
against humanity genocide is another
crime but it's a different school it's
qualitatively different and it serves no
purpose to make such comparisons the
reality of Israeli oppression is bad
enough to I mean as it stands as in this
in actuality it doesn't mean to such you
know comparison which actually has a
Mira explain very very well a disservice
to the course of those who
trying to pronounce it in the same way
that all of us line is is I mean the
best service anybody seen Kendall
designs for miranda is to engage into
anti-semitic and notice that I kind of
our statements and this this has to be
clearly understood and just see that the
uses made by providing a full out with
some internet just monitoring the whole
era bored and looking for every single
expression of this kind and just putting
it all on the internet because of course
it serves this lens education of the
enemy language about harassment of
course the case of Edom is very known
and very annoying but let's not forget
there are other scorers in Israel
universities that voice s courageous
opinions and are very active against
occupation in
in many ways and he are being arrested
and because in participating daily
weekly demonstrations and other
activities and and they remain they
might be harassed they might be bullied
but they remain and I still don't think
that we Israeli Jews are facing many
problems by being outspoken in the way
this makes Israeli how they call israel
the people who understand that such a
situation can office forever it makes
their responsibilities very heavy very
very heavy because we don't face real
real danger by being by opposing the
occupation by opposing these very
policies by voicing very
and this isn't forces it's not software
ffi it's not a Soviet Union when it
comes to dissidents so i can write in
that sense there is a democracy for
teens for sure which doesn't mean
palestinians are facing much many more
dangerous today whether we shall also be
a target so later I can you tell i don't
know but right now i have to stress it
is not it doesn't leave much courage it
needs a lot of anger yes but it doesn't
which it doesn't mean doesn't need much
coverage to write in a paper to go to a
demonstration to sign a petition even if
it goes israeli actors who called who
said they will not going to act
performing the settlement of ali air yes
they are they are braylon say because
they are endangering they are they might
have been too
etc but then in life is not eventually
our society is evolved does not excuse
me so let's not not exaggerate about the
difficulties between Israelis Israeli
Jews face when we oppose the occupation
in osara na who could have used gula and
preparing to the gulag and he did not
because the bullet is not such a
construction meta concept as our streets
but because it was established communism
I think this which is something to talk
about some profound things when mrs.
services of Warren sober occasionally um
it to me raises the importance of
context most most crucially the book
cheap burgers written provides what's so
often missing someone what's so missing
in any understanding for example the
relationship between the arms of all of
us um there is the most profound
ignorance of the Arab world and so much
what is written about this conflict
especially by people whose focus is on
Israel and some of Israelis this is
including something is relative story
ends and putting some good Israeli
historians of the Arab world I I would
mention for example that he wants who
finds himself capable of pontificate
about the Arab world without knowing the
same
word of Arabic without knowing is that
the first thing about our industry
culture language politics religion he's
a total blank on these things he's
actually in some ways a very fine
historian II more than any other
individual probably has helped to
establish the historicity of ethnic
cleansing and he's published a new
version of that book was originally
published in the late nineteen eighties
with infinitely more detail with mayors
and problems of the first broadcast when
he goes one inch over the line from his
use of listed Zionist Israeli archives
into saying anything about Arabs for the
Arab world or our history it's a black
hole in which he has absolutely no light
he knows nothing he is pathetically
ignorance topic so much of the writing
on the subject from the first book the
most in the fewer by Joseph said it was
a revisionist dynasty started this wave
that your book talks event of this
narrative is written by people who
haven't been completely innocent of a
knowledgeable and this is a beginning an
understanding of a dark of modern course
matter of Arab anti-semitism modern
forms of Arab Holocaust denial and
modern forms of Arab relations to the
Holocaust based on a profound
understanding
of the Arab world arab politics karen to
include this course there's another
quite brilliant book by israel Jeremy
and James F nasty about fascism in Egypt
anybody who dares to talk about that
hold on and hasn't been there has no
business opening their mouth without
reading that book because an
understanding of the colonial context of
your students inaudible roads and has an
abundance relationship distant though it
was to Nazism can possibly can possibly
be taken seriously that a profound
understanding of that context so these
are books that could be taken in conduct
this is not just true understanding Arab
expressions about or Arab relations to
the Hong Kong's is just as true about
understanding constant in our mystery
you cannot understand these things I
think you can understand Palestinian is
good understanding the entire course of
water dishes you or your appear at see
if you don't understand how not just how
the hell come into it but how the oldest
is an understood and internalized by the
American Jewish people but I European
Jews and survived extinction the minds
of every juice if you don't understand
that you understand nothing you can't
understand how these groups these
policies these societies related to
Palestine and Palestinians you can't
understand Palestinian history if you
don't understand the fact that before
the Nazis came to power designers
Project book like it was family
emigration from Palestine from nineteen
twenty nine to nineteen thirty three
greater than immigration to Palestine
the proportion of Jews the population of
palestine decline from nineteen twenty
nine to nineteen thirty three scientists
leaders looked at one another and said
this project may not succeed under
eighteen percent of the population with
George how would you turn Palestine into
a country that is Jewish as England was
English from 1933 until 1939 the
population ratios change the ownership
of the means of production Palestine
change from minority ownership to our
dealership from seventeen percent of
thirty-five percent and people were
forced Lee Orleans escaped with their
lives and with their human capital a
little bit of their own the capital the
very fortunate few who are not external
Holocaust completely change the balance
of power in Houston you don't understand
that you don't understand about sinister
you know nothing if you're an Arab or
Palestinian about this history that's
supposedly important to you have to
understand you have to understand the
impact of those things in terms of
changing the American Jewish community
related design ism way your pants or
anxieties if you don't understand all
the most religions an assignment none up
not only its material successful
palestine but how people's views of this
this ideology as a solution or possible
to the Jewish Question changes the
moment it becomes the power not all of
these things I think are drawing up
underlying I think what we heard here
tonight I tend to talk a little more
about some of these things we talked
about the mostest contribution to the
Nazi war ever his mentoring of the two
Bosnian divisions of the waffen-ss we
talked about his collaborators the
people who escaped to germany from iran
tehran just after literacy 90 coup in
your honor but we don't talk about as
the IRA contribution for the Allied war
the senior apprentice a was liberated by
a Brogdon and an alternative provision
two divisions they lost 5,000 men that's
1,000 Algerian and Moroccan soldiers
died liberating the city must say from
the largest importance of plans vital to
the alley were nobody talks about the
hundreds of thousands Moroccans and
Algerians who were drafted into the
French army and fought heroically to
liberate Europe nobody talks about the
Arab Legion moment he talks up for tens
of thousands of Egyptian soldiers who
were constructed and served as labor
battalions under under
hundreds of thousands of herons help
that happens win the war so you have the
movie and you have dozens of divisions
of our soldiers admittedly conscripted
into killarney's forcibly taken off to
Europe in in fact two horses happen to
do it all one as well just as it
happened the dozens to hundreds of
scores of politicians who align
themselves for private reasons for other
reasons will be British of the most deep
I've talked about this a little bit in
the cage it was just constantly the most
keen was opposed by the both of the
kasnian leadership in men ages positions
in the late thirties over the white
paper over and among other things nobody
talks like he was the paramount leader
is absolutely accurate to describe this
met as having been the most important
single policy leader at least until that
you'd be game it's also pretty
interesting however to see where other
Palestinian where other not just to look
as importantly I think at where the Arab
states came out on the issue of a Jewish
state or
continued existence intrusive Palestine
but to look at what happens to move up
the Aphrodite disappears if this man is
as important as he's made out to be then
why is he not the same kind of finger a
frenetic it's it's something that's
missing sorry I don't really touch on
mrs. I as I might have cage dude that
actually box about something these
aspects much more than I do oh I want to
thank you all for coming this evening I
hope you will attend all your events I
want you to join me in thanking to
people who i think it's go
you